alrededor de 600 migrantes viven en este
terreno baldío en la periferia de cali
durante el verano son tres veces más
numerosos se trata sobre todo de hombres
que vienen de afganistán irán irak sudán
con un objetivo llegar al reino unido
todos los días intentó pasar a reino
unido subiendo a los camiones esos
grandes camiones grandes en la primera
quincena de diciembre las carreteras que
llevan al puerto o al túnel bajo la
mancha se llenaron de largas filas de
cientos de camiones tiempo y dinero
perdido para los camioneros y una
oportunidad para numerosos migrantes que
buscan esconderse tampico no me lastran
no en el último cruce pero justo antes
intentaron subirse estaban escondidos a
orilla de la carretera y vieron que yo
era un camión británico eran unos cinco
y corrieron detrás de mí y taiwán y
nafta
la mayoría de los intentos terminan en
fracaso debido al refuerzo de los
controles aduaneros desde 2013 con la
firma de los acuerdos de tucker
franceses y británicos trabajan juntos
con herramientas cada vez más
sofisticadas el resultado las mafias
fomentan los cruces marítimos y miles de
migrantes se aventuran en pequeños botes
o embarcaciones improvisadas para
alcanzar esas costas blancas visibles
fácilmente y ubicadas a apenas 40
kilómetros de allí las ong alertan sobre
las consecuencias del break set para
estas personas que ya viven en difíciles
condiciones para la paz y para conoce la
gran duda es como el reino unido va a
salir de la reglamentación europea
cuáles leyes va a poner en práctica lo
que quieren las autoridades británicas
es poder expulsar a los exiliados a
medida que llegan a sus costas pero eso
no va a ser tan simple porque será
necesario que europa continental acepte
si esa empresa se basará con logo
continental accept
pese a las reticencias y las presiones
de cada lado en noviembre pasado parís y
londres renovaron su compromiso para
seguir luchando contra la migración
ilegal aquí en cali la gran
incertidumbre planea ahora sobre las
miles de personas que continúan
intentando llegar al reino unido a
través del canal de la mancha colon de
fuera de la unión europea el reino unido
no podrá seguir apoyándose en el derecho
comunitario para enviar de regreso esas
miles de personas hacia las costas
francesas